I just taped my own show yes and I
dashed over here mmm just in time to see
your impression of me I mean I ran over
here from my show to help out my pal the
only person I've ever given a show to
and I've run in the door I've run in and
then like want to see what's on the
screen I see you're on the screen and
it's he Gunn like
I could push a button and get another
host in here right away
they're like Dixie Cups you pulling out
another one you made a choice you made a
choice and you thought there's no way
Conan sees that yeah there was the way
he rushes over here though a man of his
stature I will tell you in your defense
they love you so much the looks of
horror when I started doing it people
were like it was is it an altar boy was
[ __ ] on the Pope's hat yeah
no one like I heard gasps and I think I
heard a woman audibly say that's just
wrong that's what I heard I did oh this
is beautiful by the way I haven't seen
your set yeah person yes yet this is a
fantastic steak restaurant
this is the best steak restaurant in
Seattle beautiful stone work that you've
done gorgeous we have a sassy waitress
to refill your eyes very good comes
along all night this is nice though yeah
it's a block of wood yeah
my son built us in Minecraft yesterday
well we wanted to be different no jacket
no desk I I the only thing I'm
self-conscious about is I have always
had the desk I always have the desk yep
I feel that my below the waist I need to
be covered at all times cuz I have body
shame issues sure and your you're more
of a let's just hang out on stools let
it out yeah all right I I've never seen
my legs that is not that is a little
that's a long leg I don't think I let's
not pretend it's just sad when you're
like I have a body proportion I have a
very tall like you yeah but you are more
reasonably proportioned I have a very
very long legs the legs of someone who's
like six nine and then I have the torso
of a little girl
so my belt is like really my genitals
are here but we've artificially moved my
belt down here to create the illusion
that I'm somewhat proportionate
correctly well they do a good job
ya know any urinal I unbutton the shirt
here
these are all facts that are true these
are true facts that's why I have a desk
but you are more recently proportional
but your appearance is above the desk
yeah yeah I'm not ashamed of my penis I
am not ashamed of where it is I'm trying
to break up the you just deconstructed
go ahead again again I push a button
this is the last 900 hosts in a
dispenser and another one just tumbles
out and goes hey great show today hey
Tommy
he brought that audience out